we were so heartbroken to hear about the
passing of one of the world's most
enduring sex symbols The Fabulous Raquel
Welch yeah Raquel you know you know they
don't make any sex symbols like that I
don't know anymore
Sonny hoston taking the heat after a
very hot topic we're gonna have a
difference of opinion so it's business
as usual on The View
turning on Thursday the ladies paid
tribute to Raquel Welch the cinema icon
died the day before following a short
illness
[Music]
Sunny shares her opinion and the table
and audience have some harsh feedback
you know they don't make any sex symbols
like that I don't know any uh
[Applause]
turning turning it's his turning yeah
panel moderator Whoopi Goldberg isn't
here for the comparison yeah that's not
even you can't even put them into I'm
not even look I'm go I'm moving on
because it's not about winning over
people it's about telling as much of the
truth as we have for fans of the talk
show Whoopi's reaction might not be a
surprise do you know how long I've been
here
just two months ago Charlize Theron told
The Hollywood Reporter the marketplace
of what Kim Kardashian represents holds
way more value than Meryl Streep and
when it came time to discuss charlise's
comment on The View Whoopi says not so
fast I'd like to speak to that Kim
Kardashian cannot get a movie Green lit
or it would have happened Whoopi even
doubles down reminding Charlize of just
how much power she has but I'll tell you
Charlize you got more pull in the
industry than I got in the industry you
can get stuff done faster than I can
this is a really great job we know who
we are we know what our place is in the
world and we try to do the best we can
well the debate can rage on but Kim's
sex symbol status can't be denied she's
had that image since the beginning yeah
Bible it's a great look
Kim even had this to say in 2007 when ET
asked if being a sex symbol had its
downsides you don't want to be like too
sexy you know you don't want people to
not be able to relate to you or that's
all that they think of you as
fast forward to 2022 Kim forever
connected herself to Marilyn Monroe
she famously wore the blonde Bombshells
JFK dressed to the Met Gala for all of
three minutes before she changed into a
replica because you know gotta preserve
the real thing I got in it I got in it
back at the table
[Applause]
another day another Hot Topic that's not
even you can't even put them into I'm
not even look I'm go I'm moving on
[Music]
thank you